- [Instructor] Let's
imagine your corn farmer
and you would dream of having
nice, healthy corn crop,
like we see in this picture.
But being a farmer isn't as
simple as planting the seeds
and making sure that the
crop gets enough sunshine
and water and fertilizer, you
also have to deal with pests.
And pests you can view as anything
that might eat your crop
or destroy your crop,
or make it just really hard
for you to have a good crop.
Now, some of you all are familiar
with the notion of pesticides,
where you're essentially
poisoning the pests.
Now for various reasons, that
might not be a good idea,
and we'll talk more about it.
And so there's a notion of
integrated pest management,
which is how we can do multiple
things which might include
pesticides or might not include
pesticides, to really keep
things under control.
And to get a good sense
of how bad a pest can be,
I will introduce you to
the Western corn rootworm.
Now, the reason why it's called a worm,
even though in its adult phase,
it does not look like a worm,
is that in its larval phase,
when it's a baby, it looks like a worm.
And even though the adult will
also feed on the corn silks,
the real damage is done
in the larval stage.
When they're feeding on the roots,
that's why they're called corn rootworms.
And the USDA estimates that
just in the United States,
damage due to Western
corn rootworm is about
$1 billion per year.
About 800 million of that,
is just lost corn crop.
And about 200 million of that
is all the costs in order
to prevent this pest
from doing their damage.
Now, as I mentioned, if we think about
integrated pest management,
there's many ways of addressing this.
One way of course, that many
people think of, is pesticides.
And this is an image of crop dusting.
I don't think this is a corn field here,
we can see the pesticides
coming from the biplane.
And it's a way of
spreading the pesticides,
not the only way, but for various reasons,
this is not optimal.
You could view it as
polluting the environment
in certain ways.
A lot of us aren't so keen on eating crops
that have pesticides on them.
And we've learned in other
videos on evolution and natural
selection, there's
variation in any population.
And the more that you expose
a population to something,
and it kills off the ones
that are susceptible,
the more chances that the ones
that aren't as susceptible,
reproduce and thrive.
So at some point you might
have an insecticide resistant
pest on your hands and
then your insecticide,
isn't going to be all that useful.
So when we think about
integrated pest management,
we think about art,
what are other ways to address this?
Maybe in conjunction, maybe ways
that could be perceived
to be more natural?
Well one obvious thing
is to think about, well,
what are the predators of that pest?
And this is the wasp spider,
and this is what's known as
a ladybug in North America
and ladybird in much of
the rest of the world.
And they will actually feed
on the Western corn rootworm.
So you might want to
introduce this onto your farm
if you're trying to grow that corn.
Another thing that farmers have done
to some degree of success,
is early planting.
By planting the crop early,
it's less favorable for the
root worm to lay their eggs.
And also it gives a chance
for the roots to get stronger,
so that by the time that they're
attacked by the rootworm,
they're going to be more resilient.
You could also have
hybrid versions of corn
that just have larger roots.
So once again, they're going to be more
resilient to the rootworm.
Another technique is to
genetically modify the corn.
And that also is a bit
of a controversial topic,
depending on who you talk to.
You might've heard things about GMO,
genetically modified organism.
Some people think they're fine.
Some people are wary of them.
But there is a transgenic version of corn.
Transgenic means, that we took
DNA from some other organism
and put it into the corn.
And that transgenic version
is known as BT corn.
That actually has DNA from a bacteria,
which produces a protein,
which is harmful to certain
types of root worms.
Now, another really interesting technique,
which people have used to
some degree of success,
is known as crop rotation.
Let's imagine looking down from the sky
onto a corn crop here.
So we're looking down from above.
So what normally happens is,
is that the eggs are laid near the corn
and the larvae can't travel so far.
So they, if they're near the corn,
they get to the roots
and then they're able to,
the reproduction cycle goes on.
But if we rotate the crops so
that the next year we're not
planting here, but maybe we
are planting the corn over here
and then in that first place,
we're planting soybean.
Well, that can solve the problem,
because the eggs will be laid here.
But next year the corn
is going to be here.
And over here, we will have the soybean,
which is not a suitable
food for the corn rootworm.
Now what's really interesting,
and this is another one of
those fascinating stories
of evolution and natural selection,
are there cases because there's
variation in populations,
where some of the adult rootworm
actually doesn't lay their
eggs in the same corn
crop, where they feed,
they lay it in an adjacent corn crop.
So that next year when
the crop rotation happens,
then their larva are going
to have access to the corn
in the other field.
Now you might say, how did they know that?
How did they know that the
farmers were planning to rotate?
Well, generally the
rotations are pretty simple.
You keep alternating between two crops
like corn and soybean.
And most of the Western corn rootworm
would not have done that,
but just some of them might
have started to randomly travel
a little bit further.
And then those would be
more likely to reproduce.
So the ones are more likely to reproduce
will then exist more.
And then that behavior would be passed on,
if it is a genetic trait.
There's other situations once again,
because of the variation in populations,
where some of the eggs stay
dormant for an extra year.
So even though you might
rotate to corn this year,
the year after that,
you rotate back to corn
and then the eggs hatch
and the larva can feed.
So it's a fascinating, almost arms race,
between the farmer and these pests.
But I hope you appreciate,
it's far more interesting
than you might have realized before.
And I haven't even given
you a comprehensive list
of all the types of
pests and all of the ways
that you might want to manage it.
You can do physical removal,
you could do barriers.
Maybe you'll think of another creative way
to have integrated pest management.